if Jim I've been here about a year and a
half I was hired to help think about how
we might better engage improve our
mathematics instruction so so we've got
several things going a lot gonna talk
about it only one of those today and as
you might imagine my point of view on
online education is how does it actually
enhance our local experience now there's
plenty of great uses of online education
to reach students around the world to
reach students who have don't have the
resources to to come and have a local
experience lots of good reasons my point
of view is what piece of this feeds back
into what I do in the classroom on
Tuesdays and Thursday from 1135 to 1250
now in light of that the question I
think is how can we leverage two things
video and online testing quizzing etc to
do this so in order to give you some
sense of how we're thinking about this I
need to give you a sense of where we are
currently in the life of a typical
student coming into a Yale mathematics
classroom so you come into the classroom
and what happens in the classroom that
the professor or the other lecturer
walks up finds their favorite piece of
chalk and they start writing copious
notes pristine notes as a matter of fact
on the chalkboard with chalk flying
everywhere and the students doing what
copying furiously and trying to get
every single jot and tiddle including
the dust pictures and the cloud of dust
in the room into their notes so that
what might happen next they go home they
say have some homework to do some
problem sets we will give about 11 or 12
once a week pretty much every week for
the semester and then they for the first
time perhaps crack the book open I know
this because I asked I asked students in
about 13 14 15 % of our students
actually crack the textbook open before
they come to class which means almost no
one does and as a matter of fact I'm
pleasantly surprised that it's even that
not so for the first time students might
encounter the material in the textbook
after they've seen it in class because
they have a problem set to do right
and then what happens we like to give
them challenging problems as one might
expect and so for the first time they
have these harder problems they're
wrestling with by themselves in the
loathsomeness of their room and they go
oh my goodness what just happened here I
need some help and so maybe they go to a
peer tutor maybe they go to office hours
maybe they go to problem-solving session
and at that point they seek out help and
then they have an exam where they are
tested on the knowledge that they copied
down copiously while the chalk dust was
flying everywhere in the room which they
studied in these hard problems sets by
themselves maybe they wouldn't got some
help and then of course this process
goes over and over and over and over
again so in light of this this this
process what we wanted to do in our
particular take on this is we wanted to
deconstruct the classroom sequence into
three components and these components
are not particularly known fact a lot of
people here today have talked about each
of these in meaningful ways and so to
help me sort of keep it straight in my
own mind what should go where I've got
this little this little acronym here in
form confirm extent our ice framework
that helps me think about what you're
going into these so prior to come in
class we're gonna give them the basic
information that used to happen on the
chalkboard the chalk dust flying
everywhere that happens before they come
to class then the second thing is we
want them to confirm their understanding
of what they just seen we don't want
them of course to watch passively this
information so we ask them to manipulate
and retrieve what they've just seen very
via online quizzes and then we want to
really give them a pretty pretty hard
push a pretty hard kick when they come
to class still really try to extend
their understanding so we're trying to
create close ties and links between each
of these elements that ultimately result
in the student moving from point A first
encountering this basic information to
deeper more sophisticated understandings
so of course the video is the thing that
happens as as we know the great thing
about video is it can happen anytime
anyplace and the
user the student is controlling learning
speed not the instructor which is what
happens when you come to class and then
I'm going to give you a sample here in a
second you're going to see the visuals
are much better than at least anything I
can produce in the classroom so let me
give you just a sense I've got the sound
off because honestly the sounds not the
point so one of the things that happens
we had a graphics guys they Matt Matt
cross bun that did all this as as Mike
said earlier we had this framing thing
it's my ugly mug up in the in the frame
at the start at the end but not in
between I'm just trying to frame what
the big idea is for today and I'm happy
to be talking about adding up an
infinite number of objects here and we
asked this question when you have an
infinite sum is it a value instead of
meaning how do we interpret this and so
one of the points in this little sample
right here is that the graphics guy had
was great he would always ask Jim and
this 10 to 12 minutes sample that we're
gonna do for the students to watch
what's the mathematical story that we're
gonna try to tell now I don't know about
you but as a mathematician I don't think
about stories in class I think about
things in class and so this is a very
new and different way for me to think he
would also sort of try to begin to think
it's a Jim how can we visually represent
the kinds of thing that you're doing in
the classroom on the video screen and so
you're seeing lots of things that pop up
and this is all happening ways that is
almost impossible for me to replicate in
the classroom via a lecture so the
visuals are very nice a subtly and
sometimes explicitly reinforce the
mathematical ideas that I want to
communicate in ways they're simply
impossible for me to do otherwise so
let's get out of this and so later on
after I get out of picture things start
happening where I'm annotating the
screen again it resolves it's a nice
typeset mathematics if you if you caught
I had a very brief glimpse of me
annotating things my handwriting's
terrible it's just flat terrible is bad
and so we need to resolve it it's a nine
I accept things you see animations that
go on but again are really nice and
difficult for me to produce in the
classroom so the basic informed piece of
this little framework
Able's the user controls that the
visuals provide I think so some
different ways of thinking and
understanding the mathematics that that
simply do not have at least what I when
I lecture so then of course we moved
from there to the confirmed piece the
students complete some online quizzes we
happen to use a Coursera to deliver the
video and the quizzes and the basic idea
is that students learn best by testing
as opposed to studying that's the theory
at least and so we're implementing this
and so the students are confirming to
themselves what they know and don't know
based on what they just seen in the
video but more than that they're
confirming to me what they saw what they
understand what they don't understand
because the reality is 5:30 6:00 a.m. on
Tuesday Thursdays I'm up in front of my
computer with my extremely large cup of
coffee looking at the results from the
quizzes and so if a student does 80% on
average the class is around 80% got this
one right well I'm fine with that
I don't focus on it 30% right on this
one okay we're talking about this
example in class in more detail and then
of course the last question that I ask
is what did you not really understand in
the video or what was particularly
interesting and guess what they tell me
and almost exclusively they tell me what
they didn't get and is it ever
illuminating I'd go into class and I
sort of think yeah I've been teaching
for a while I know how this is gonna
roll they're gonna not get this and
that's what I'm gonna focus on and then
all of a sudden last fall's we're
running this these these things are
coming through I'm going to oh goodness
they're telling me they didn't
understand something I thought was
pretty fundamentally pretty basic Wow I
had no clue so to my sense of what is
really going on in their minds how they
think about this is greatly increased
because of the streams of data that come
in from the
and from the prep clubs that we have
them do and then of course we ask them
to come to class I saw this is a
screenshot of some of the prep problems
here the first one you make a
computation you input a function there's
sort of several different kinds of
problems that you can ask and the second
one is a multiple-choice one so it's a
Coursera it's fairly nice in that way
the last question I've already mentioned
here and then of course class is much
better tailored to focus on points of
confusion and misconceptions here we
then spend times on the harder more
nuanced ideas the more difficult
problems that they back in the day when
the chalk bus was fly we're spending by
themselves working on this so presumably
experts in the subject which hopefully
is myself would be present to help them
dive deeper and deal with some of the
more sophisticated ideas as opposed to
asking them to wrestle with these things
by themselves so assessment of this
whole little project that we've been
doing here we collected lots of data
last fall almost all that came in the
last couple of weeks of the semester
performance data on exams we had
observers come into class try to get us
give us a sense of what they think was
going on in terms of student learning
pre post surveys on attitudes pre post
exams on performance again we ran a
couple of focus groups so we had three
basic research questions one and these
these are very broad they're way too
broad
we'll have to refine these in the future
are the students actually learn anything
in a significant way that's different
from the traditional lecture approach
and actually to say it's even use even
more than that I compared primarily one
of my sections which was flipped versus
one of mine which was not flipped to
control for instructor effects here and
my non-video class is very active I'm a
big fan of active learning so really
this the comparison we made were again
flipped plus active learning against
active learning here and so lots of data
and I just say oh in terms of a
performance point of view on exams
neutral observers etc extremely positive
but to be honest there is mountains of
data there and so instead of trotting
out lots of Statistics that I may have
to change next week I would just say
it's going in the right direction right
now and we hope to have a better more
detailed report later in the semester
about that on what the student State
student opinion is on average extremely
positive
can we other instructors leverage this
approach so so if this is an effective
thing to do is it possible for other
instructors to pick this up and use the
videos and their own spin of what needs
to happen in class and so this spring
where we're testing that with two
additional instructors so a couple of
what the students think sort of things
we asked them the video problem in class
experience was that helpful for your
learning you either agree strongly agree
disagree disagree strongly or neutral
72% of them said yes we think it's
helpful and only nine percent said now
we really would prefer some other points
of view here then we go further than
that and say is it not only helpful is
it more helpful than traditional
learning and you see that 65% of them
said yes it's more helpful than the
traditional lecture approach and 15%
disagree with that statement of course
there are some neutrals in there as well
so summary this is not a particularly
new approach to teaching for four
decades for a very long time people have
tried to help students prepare before
they come to class
I must confess I have been spectacularly
unsuccessful in that endeavor before
this particular experience they just
simply choose not to prepare before they
come to class at least in the way I've
tried to incentivize and motivate them
but the tools that we're using for this
are are of course newer and so we're
trying to put things together in a
distinctive way our preliminary
assessment as I've mentioned is very
positive and of course as everybody has
said this clearly takes a team guy we'll
leave it back in the back at Karis is
here Lucas many many others many people
that I haven't put up here we're a part
of all this any questions